you had to come with a little bit more
than just the best players all them
people that they say are the best to
ever do it yeah my teams beat all them
[Music]
welcome to full body i'm channing fry as
the wines get darker the questions gonna
get deeper let's go isaiah thomas zeke
coach boss mentor first of all thank you
so much for taking the time uh to be
here with us on full bodied it's amazing
to me to be able to open up another
african-american man's champagne oh most
definitely this is one of my favorite
things about being in the champagne in
in the wine space is that you get to you
know pop
and drink and sip and
you get to have great conversation
where did this idea or opportunity come
from you're an inner city kid from
chicago
you're are you the only black man that
owns champagne grapes in
champaign i'm the only black man and i'm
the only american that owns the grapes
uh in champaign as you know they won't
let an american own land there so we own
all the rights to the grapes that come
off the land that allows us to give you
the first press of the great and what i
discovered is that here in america a lot
of the champagnes that we get are second
and third press loaded with sugar very
high in sulfites so consequently you get
a headache when you drink it this is all
a champion and it is a hundred percent
you probably won't find another 100
pinot in the united states and if you do
it's maybe one or two of them this is
delicious you've had every single job
you've been a coach you've been a gm
you've been an owner you've been a
player when you were playing did you
know
when i get done these are the things
that i want to accomplish even when i
was playing i was what you might call a
serial entrepreneur i experimented a lot
you know in business uh and a lot of it
came around the city of detroit and in
michigan i started a candy bar called
isaiah bars after the reggie jackson
bars after the reggie bar
put that on the shelf and then i
partnered with stro's ice cream put
stro's ice cream into the supermarkets
into the shelf and then the next product
as you talked about was popcorn because
i love popcorn yup and
i know it uh so we did you entered that
time square that popcorn was hidden yeah
i'm a popcorn guy man yeah you remember
that see why you got into champagne
you're celebrating all these wins you
ain't got no losses
well
this champagne is called a champion you
got to look at this color channing i'm
always fascinated by
how you know that the color of the
champagne is and
how tight the bubbles are
and enchanting you will notice as this
champagne kind of settles a little bit
it gets a lot smoother and that's what i
love about this champagne some
champagnes you drink and you have a
whole fight in your mouth
uh
you know you have to swish it around and
stuff before you can even swallow it
so the e-wrap
when i first saw this you know i'm i'm
old and my my eyes ain't so good right
but i play it off because i don't want
to put the glasses on
so right when i first looked at it i was
like oh this earth champagne i mean
earth wine
i called it earth
yeah this is uh earth wind and fire
exactly exactly it only comes out in
september ah there you go that's nice i
like that
this is a white pinot noir ebrath has
been around and is one of the better
producers in the willamette valley
whether that's smoke or whether that's
something going on with the skins of the
grape they have to take the skins off
and press right right yeah yeah so
you're getting the essence
of the pinot noir without the color yeah
let's go back just a little bit farther
you told me a story you growing up
having your coach in your house on your
recruiting visit with your mom and your
brother there yeah tell everybody that
story and then i'll bring it back around
to this wine so i'm assuming that you're
talking about uh
coach knight when i was uh
being recruited to go to indiana
university and as you know we were we
were poor than poor when coach and i
came to visit we had no electricity and
and so when he came over all my brothers
was there you know my mom was there and
we had been offered a lot of things to
go to different colleges you know money
and right you know cars and homes and
and again we had nothing blue chips yeah
i mean i mean i actually turned down
blue chips
it came back to you yeah we got offered
all kinds of things right and this one
college coach came to our house opened
up a briefcase and said hey there's
fifty thousand dollars in here if your
son comes to this college you get fifty
thousand dollars now chanting we had
never seen fifty thousand dollars before
in our life as far as we know it could
have only been a thousand dollars in
their free case
and so now coach knight comes and i
remember him sitting there saying you
know mrs thomas you know i'm only going
to offer your son three things a he's
gonna get a good education b i'm gonna
teach him everything i know about the
game of basketball and see he'll be a
gentleman you know i remember my
brothers looking at me and me looking at
them like well okay well we're not going
to indiana i mean
this ain't going to work you know just
so chanting so now the
the lights are going down so it's
getting darker in the house
and as it's getting a little darker you
know we have roaches right so there's a
there's a roach that's crawling right
behind coach knight
and i'm like oh please go back please go
back in
and the roach is crawling down the wall
and i'm saying to myself oh man i hope
don't nobody see that roach coming down
the wall
so now you know the conversation gets
you know they get to talking about where
are you going to play and you know how
how's it going to be at indiana my mom
asked coach knight you know a pretty
serious question
she said you know the the clan is in
martinsville indiana if my son gets into
you know any type of issues who's going
to protect him you know he said well
you know if we're winning
mrs thomas the clan will protect him
oh my god he said that to your mother
yeah but you know in a joking kind of
way right my brother's like you like he
didn't he didn't think that was a joke
so he was like yo yeah yeah if you mean
so forth and so on coach knight was like
well you know it's just a joke another
so now i look over at my brother and
he's lit now he ready to fight and coach
knight said something back to him
and then he said well you know if you
want to do something now we can take
this outside
and i'll never forget coach knight got
up took his jacket off
rolled up the sleeves and said yeah we
can go outside
and so now the whole house is in the
uproar right my mother is sitting there
and
you know i'm looking at her for for her
reaction right and her guidance like
what am i supposed to do with this yeah
and she's sitting there like this
[Music]
and i'm like
oh no she
she liked him
right
and so it it didn't get into nothing you
know they broke it up and everything and
my mom had a press conference
i was sitting next to her and she said
my son has made his decision
he's decided that he's going to indiana
university to play for coach bob knight
and i was sitting there like this
[Music]
but
you had no choice decisions she made
here's what i'll say about that
i both of us have been coached by
amazing coaches throughout our nba
career throughout our college career
and one thing they didn't do
was look at us based on our skin they
looked at us
as men they looked at us as how can they
how could i make them better like how
can i how can they make the other pieces
that i have better right and i feel like
when you have an opportunity to have a
vineyard right and things don't go the
the
exact way you're looking at how can i
still tell this story right um and so
for me this white pinot noir forever
will be
whether it is this 2015 or whether it's
2020 or whatever year white pinot to me
is making the best
out of sometimes tough situations i
think you're different
right from a lot of gm's or a lot of
owners and a lot of coaches because
they want to shy away from the personal
relationships with players right that
it's not business that relationship and
that trust is some people just they put
players on a carousel yeah right without
getting to know them and they want to
talk you can't talk to each player the
same way to tell you something with
craziers i still live in portland you've
sent me where i've lived for 14 years
yeah we're gonna open up this last pinot
[Music]
when you were playing
who were guys that you felt like you had
to have the utmost preparedness for and
respect obviously it was jordan
obviously it was bird obviously it was
magic but who are some of the guys some
of the unknowns that you were like this
dude can go but just
doesn't get enough credit for it the
first thing that comes to mind right now
is maurice cheeks who just went into the
hall of fame now mo cheeks is from
chicago also and i remember when i when
i first came into the league
you know philadelphia was rolling
chatting they were rolling i mean he
andrew tony
you know bobby jones dr j moses malone
it was like lionel hollander like damn
like
where did we get a break you know most
guards would slide their feet or mow
cheeks hopped yeah you know and and so
they gave him
that gave him an extra quick quickness
and the extra bounce
and so i would go through my stuff
real hard between my legs to get my best
shake and he'll say
and i was like oh man just be still be
there still be there oh and and i
couldn't shake him but he was the guy
that that gave me the most problems
defensively these are stories that i
think
we need to continue to tell about
different players you know in today's
media we we
always talk about the top 20 of the top
50 but each
generation there are so many players
that get overlooked that had a huge
influence like there's no james harden
if manu ginobili doesn't come with that
euro step first yes
right and that should be the story like
james harden is amazing
but manu ginobili like and here's the
truth we swept the spurs in 2010. you
know who was the only dude that we had
to double team was manu ginobili when
they ran that sideline screen when they
ran that one four one five if you had to
have like a starting five of
these dudes are just hoopers who don't
get enough credit from your generation
who would they be starting with guards
the coaching of today is so drastically
different than it was back then i'm sure
magic johnson would have probably had
two or three coaches fired
because
the coaches would have been looking at
him like
oh well you're a six nine center
and you don't shoot the three so we
can't play you at the point guard
position
you know
i mean you're not wrong
and so in this area of basketball it
would have been it would have been
interesting to see you know who would
have been successful from all era in
this era
and what positions would have had to
change and who would have the nerve as a
coach
to change their coaching style to make
those guys successful i think a lot of
coaches coach what makes them successful
not coaching to win and what's best for
their players even though it's
uncomfortable for them yeah right and i
think some coaches go this is what i
know this is what we're gonna do
culturally you could do that as a coach
but when it comes to the skills and the
talents of your players
your offensive defense has to be 100
representative of who's out there
playing yeah you're coaching you're not
playing how many players really have in
their vocabulary what you just
articulated
is
i'm playing to make winning plays
to win the game yeah i'm not trying to
cover my cover my ass with stats right i
was the beginning of the social media
era right what happened was z can you
you're attest to this when you would
lose in a newspaper they would say so
and so lost and then that was it there
wasn't no highlight tape where you could
cut it were you dunking no you could be
down 50 and people are like man he's so
good no you're not good you're not
winning yes
right yeah and so for me
you players are falling in love with the
fate you lost yeah you're a loser
right yeah that would hurt right if you
weren't at the championship game you
weren't playing at the phoenix suns
arena america west arena you didn't have
all the girls on you yeah they were like
oh yeah yeah what are you like
gross yeah right you know it hurt hey my
dad used to drop me off at six in the
morning at this place called kiwanis
park in chandler arizona cause six in
the morning he would have me play
against grown men yes right so now i'm
12 13 14. i'm playing 30 year old men
yeah i'm six foot two they think i'm a
little bigger than what i am that's
where you learn shot selection at
[Laughter]
well that's where you learn listen you
don't want to be somewhere from 6 a.m to
2 p.m and be sitting on the side every
single time yeah to switch back to this
wine right so this pinot noir is
granville it's the farmhouse cuvee
jackson is the man yeah this is this is
jackson is a second generation his dad
was a grower he knows the willamette
valley like the back of his hand he's
making it in more new age this is a wine
that is like the middle of the week wine
where you're like i just want a pure
pinot noir i want what willamette valley
tastes like and this is it it's a smooth
you know
goes down easy there is no new oak on
this and that to me is
what makes really good wine it's
restraint and and for me
it's drinkable it's approachable it's
like not you don't feel a certain way
about it except this is delicious i
remember one of my first um
uh tastings right and they and they said
you know spit it out right now i was
like okay and i did that as the day went
on you know you just started smelling it
right
and oh yeah what i didn't know is that
you can get a high from smelling it
like oh man is that what got you in the
other industry if you just walk around
and you just smelling it you like
actually you know what got me in the
other industry and the cannabis in the
hemp space it's actually my son my son
and my daughter you know they're younger
so
yeah yeah yeah you know they would
assume they indulge right
but then my son and my daughter started
saying hey you know
you you need to start studying this a
little bit more because it helps with my
anxiety it helps with my depression
right my daughter has narcolepsy and you
know i wore shoes today so show us your
shoes the sleep project everybody should
check it out but my daughter was
diagnosed with narcolepsy the doctors
were saying hey why don't you you try a
little you know marijuana for your
depression or your anxiety or whatever
that's when i really started looking
into the plan but i've gotten into the
business i'm vice chairman ceo of this
company called one world farmer if you
had to get five players from today's
game
and play
a seven game series
against the your bad boy pistons who
would those players be the the question
is what rules are we planned by we're
playing by the 80s rules your rules i'ma
pick a team that talent-wise would give
us a hard time you would break them yeah
well our mentality was and what all and
what our defensive scheming was right it
all depends on what coach
you put with these five players
because you just weren't going to beat
us with talent we proved that against
the lakers chicago and boston you had to
come with a little bit more than just
the best players because we're going to
make you think
for two and a half hours and for 48
minutes and if there's a weak link on
your team
are we going to exploit that that type
of mentality is the most ferocious
mentally grinding mentality
and like you've you've proven that that
works only for y'all like yeah you can't
copy that style if you're talking to the
top 25 best players ever
yeah you beat
three of the top ten in their teams
all of them
all them people that they say are out of
are the best to ever do it yeah my teams
beat all them
you know we probably was the best
defensive team to ever play in the nba
now they've showed you some highlights
of us uh they showed a few clips of us
following people hard and then they you
know wrote a few paragraphs around it
and they said okay this is the pistons
but when you go back and you watch the
pistons play and you talk to all the
coaches that you've played for
all of them are trying to emulate the
way we play defense they tell you from
one perspective but they don't show you
the whole game still the highest scoring
game ever in the nba is held by who the
detroit pistons at 186 points that's
what we scored
grandmas and grandpas
we was playing against the denver
nuggets
186 winners
it's the altitude the highest scoring
game ever right how many games have you
actually seen
of the detroit pistons in your lifetime
think about that
i mean to be honest off top i've only
seen clips of dennis rodman doing his
thing yeah
when you hurt your ankle
right but i've never they don't really
show
you guys as a whole even though you're
champions
those who haven't become champions can't
understand that sacrifice
don't understand that journey
and therefore
they lower the bar
and say that
you were just lucky to be on the
championship team i think we have the
greatest championship
in the history of basketball one hundred
percent only yes that's how i feel
down 3-1 in the nba finals
to
historically they were saying one of the
greatest teams to ever play and come
back
and win the series that is the greatest
feat
in nba championship play
that i've ever witnessed in my life
the basketball game is 40 minutes but
being a basketball player is 24 7. 24 7.
i talked to my wife
four minutes i said hey baby hey i love
you okay i gotta go back on my team yeah
stretching together we're eating
together we're recovering together even
if somebody was just getting a massage
you'd have three four people in the room
watching film talking singing we were so
close yes right and not
after all these available
we have a group text
where we text every night
and and in the text we'll say i love you
we'll say you know f you right right
wish each other happy birthdays what you
just talked about again in terms of that
that sacrifice
that discipline
how many players
are willing to make that braun
plays
for
lineage braun plays for
mount rushmore of nba
this man plays every game
to try to be the greatest player of all
time
so when you look at his schedule and how
he eats how he approaches a game what he
knows what he doesn't know how he talks
is on a level that when you humble
yourself and say
okay you are different yeah then you can
accept who he is and why he acts the way
he does i'm gonna give you two stories
and
to
to punctuate what you just said about
lebron but i said to him i said you know
you have to accept the challenge of
trying to be the greatest player to ever
play because not many of us including
myself has ever had the opportunity to
play
for being the greatest player to ever
play fast forward right he asked me okay
what do i i say you got you got to
become smarter at the game i said the
brain
is a muscle
so you have to start reading before the
game so when it's time for you to go out
and play
your brain is firing you're the one that
told him that i'm the one that told him
that who are the players that that we
had to beat so magic johnson kareem
abdul-jabbar they thought like lebron
james they understood that type of
detail in the game larry bird dennis
johnson
they understood that type of detail in
the game so when you talk about playing
against those guys channing in my era
we had three teams in terms of philly
boston and la that they had two to three
guys on a team
that thought like lebron
that's how good those teams were to beat
those teams you had to have your own
unique hot sauce yeah you couldn't you
couldn't use somebody else's sauce on
their chicken yeah hot sauce you had to
bring your own type of sauce exactly hey
man like i said you can run fast you can
jump high you can dunk you can do all
that stuff but if you can't think ah we
can ready to kill you what do you want
people to think about your legacy i
would say as a as a person overcoming
all the obstacles and the odds of
growing up on the west side below the
poverty line i was the kid that wasn't
supposed to make it to 18 wasn't
supposed to graduate from college wasn't
supposed to get into uc berkeley and get
a master's in education i was the kid
that strived to get out of the
the ghetto strive to get out of hard
times
and then i happen to play basketball
your personhood your honesty your trust
uh your your sacrifice your discipline
like you know who are you as a person
and i would want people to remember me
as the person i was not necessarily the
basketball player i was because if all
you can remember me for is that i was a
good basketball player then i've done a
bad job with the rest of my life thank
you man i mean zeke obviously like i
would do this for hours with you i
appreciate your time you're the best
thanks for being on full bodies thank
you and i love you
and i really mean that i love you too
man you're the best thank you
[Music]